well 2018 is drawing to a close thank
god it's once again time to sit down and
talk about the best films that were
released this year these are factual
choices actual real scientifically
proven choices there is no opinion here
I am absolutely right and there is
nothing you can say about it
jokes aside 2018 was a rough year for
movies there were a lot of great films
don't get me wrong it's just that the
majority of the films that I was really
excited to see were very disappointing
this was the first year ever that I
didn't give my highest grade no new
release got an A+ this year and that's
kind of sad that being said there were
actually quite a few really good movies
when I sat down and really thought about
it and especially because I was able to
get my hands on some screeners for
certain films because this is the very
first year that I've ever actually
gotten screeners which is such big help
it's really really helped me in regards
to you know seeing some of these smaller
films because here in Ohio I don't get a
lot of those until way later one of
those being if Beale Street could talk
which is my first honorable mention
other honorable mentions include creed
to love Simon Black Klansmen Incredibles
to a quiet place searching won't you be
my neighbor the night is short walk on
girl Roma an eighth grade all of those
movies are great and I recommend
checking out all of them the fact that
they're not on the list is just because
there were 10 others I liked more which
is I think obvious but I know how the
internet works the fact that this is
just a list with numbers is because
everybody else does that if I just
listed off a bunch of movies I loved it
wouldn't really be that exciting it's a
lot more exciting when there's numbers
burning is a South Korean film that I
gratefully got a screener for because I
wouldn't have been able to see it
otherwise I thought this movie was
insanely good it's a drama thriller and
it sort of reveals itself to be a
thriller like you start watching it and
it almost comes off at first because I
knew nothing about the movie didn't know
the plot
nothing about it not the synopsis
nothing it almost comes off like a
romantic drama for a while but it slowly
reveals itself to have these really dark
terrible things going on under the
surface and it's fascinating it's
extremely well helmed and very well
acted I highly recommend checking it out
when it comes to a theater near you or
is released on VOD because it's one of
the best probably my favorite foreign
yeah it's my favorite foreign film of
2018 at number 9 Paddington - this movie
was great I mean I was talking to
somebody on Facebook recently a buddy of
mine and he and I I mentioned how much I
love Paddington too and he was like
really I was like dude just go watch it
it's really really good it's a
great children's film one of the best
family movies I've seen in recent years
and I couldn't really fault the movie it
was really hard to fault a movie it was
just enjoyable from seeing one and I
really hope they make a third because in
regards to family entertainment like
especially live-action family
entertainment this is one of the best
I've really ever seen at number eight
everyone's favorite Oscar pick a star is
born
performances off the charts Lady gaga
Bradley Cooper Sam Elliott who is my
pick for Best Supporting Actor and I
think should definitely get a lot more
attention for that insane one of his
best ever and that guy's a legend he's
better I mean he was in Roadhouse for
God's sakes at number seven Avengers
infinity war a movie that I thought was
good when I first saw it I liked it a
lot and with subsequent viewings I just
I loved the movie now I think it's a
really well made superhero film it's
really easy to look at films like this
and discredit them because they're
popular and they're about superheroes I
mean it's been that way since I was a
kid if you like superheroes and you were
a kid you know you didn't have any
friends at school it's a little
different now but it's really easy to
discredit the amount of work that
actually went into this movie that most
people myself included can't even
comprehend just from a visual effects
perspective it's genuinely stunning and
one of the best Marvel movies at number
six Green Book another film that I got a
screener for and I was very grateful
for that because it took a while to come
to Ohio films that deal with this
subject matter but take a crowd-pleasing
approach or a more fun light-hearted
approach are often looked down upon
especially in the press nowadays and I
think that that's a bad thing I think
that movies that are a little more
digestible and easier to watch for
mainstream audiences that deal with this
type of subject matter could potentially
result in some good because some of the
darker films others just don't even want
to see but a film like this that you can
watch and be entertained by with two
incredible performances both
oscar-worthy from Viggo Mortensen and
Marcia Ali I think a film like this
could really do some good yeah there's
some scenes that people don't appreciate
and I can understand that but I just
found the craft to be really well done
the writing to be just extremely
hilarious the music also really good and
for someone as popular as Viggo
Mortensen is who's who's done everything
really to have a role like this at this
point in his career that's pretty
impressive at number five probably the
most surprising movie of the year for me
spider-man into the spider-verse
I have been a lifelong fan of spider-man
and he's probably my favorite superhero
so to see an animated film done this
well with so much care was such a unique
visual look to it and a story that we
have not yet seen in the spider-man
films was just such a blessing to be
honest for for this comic book fan at
number four blind spotting probably the
most overlooked film of the year this
movie I thought was genius
one of my favorite screenplays of the
year hilarious
subversive takes similar to Green Book
some very intense and horrific subject
matter and it found a way to weave some
very real biting satirical comedy into
it and I thought it was just so well
done the final rap song maybe my
favorite scene of the year there are
other movies obviously that I liked more
in regards to singular scenes and
moments in movies the final rap song in
this movie is just insane at number 3
annihilation
a film that was very polarizing for for
some audiences but for me and my friend
group that went and saw the movie we
were just enthralled by it
and it's one of those sci-fi movies that
I just I love I love films like this or
under the skin that just feel like
they're on a different level some some
different form of filmmaking that other
movies they just don't even try or
attempt because they're too afraid this
film wasn't afraid it was a really
ballsy sci-fi movie with great
performances incredible special effects
and some of my favorite sequences of the
whole year at number two the best action
film I've seen since Mad Max fury road
Mission Impossible fallout I've been a
fan of the series since the 90s and I've
been pulling for this series since then
it's a series filled with incredible
sequels i mean ii was really the only
one i didn't like but 3 was much better
than 2 4 was much better than 3 5 is
great don't love it as much as four but
6 it's the best in the whole lot it's
one of the best sequels ever mates one
of the best action movies ever made it's
probably yeah it's got to be the best
sixth movie in a franchise ever and no
return that jedi doesn't count
this film gave me everything I wanted as
an action fan it had real stunts it had
helicopters flying through mountains it
had Tom Cruise in like the best running
shot ever my friend John Flickinger he
he likes to with me when we were in
the theater sitting together this this
great 360 panning shot that ends with
him jumping when he you know he broke
his ankle I actually said out loud oh
Jesus like it just gave me everything I
wanted as a gigantic Mission Impossible
fan and I might be biased but I just
genuinely think this is one of the best
action movies in maybe 5 6 7 years it's
just so so good but it didn't reach me
on an emotional level you know like I I
appreciated its technical presentation
so much and I respect it so much because
I know how hard it is to make a tiny
little
movie for like a couple hundred bucks
like when I see a film like this it just
I have to respect it and it's so goddamn
entertaining but it didn't reach me on
an emotional level the way my number one
pick did and my favorite film of 2018
was hereditary hereditary like the which
it comes at night the babadook was a
very polarizing film for audiences
critics loved it everybody was excited
about it but it's not a mainstream movie
like a quiet place you know it's not a
movie that everybody can go to and enjoy
it's sometimes a very uncomfortable film
it kind of makes you cringe a little bit
in a good way you know like you're
sitting back like oh I don't know if I
want to watch this sort of intricate
display of a family breaking down and
it's it's uncomfortable and it makes
people feel like they don't enjoy what
they're seeing I thought this movie was
an incredible horror film all the more
amazing because it's first-time feature
for director airy Esther who I can't
wait to see what else he does toni
collette I believe deserves an Oscar
nomination everyone in the movie was
just insanely good one of the best
directed horror films I've really ever
seen and I loved everything about it
there were just a few pacing issues I
had that kept it from getting the
perfect day plus grade but in regards to
horror movies this is the exact type of
film that I would like to make if I was
given the opportunity or if I had the
chance with a budget I loved it and I
highly recommend it if you didn't get to
see it when I was out in the theaters
guys those are my favorite movies of
2018 I'm looking forward to a 2019 this
is actually the first year in history
where I'm actually really excited for
January I got the Dragon Ball super
movie which could go both ways who knows
but then glass oh my god glass is in
January so I'm actually looking forward
to January for once I also want to
quickly briefly talk about one very
important thing and that is the worst of
the Year video I've done one every year
but I'm gonna be really honest and
transparent with you guys because I
believe that you would prefer that I
haven't really enjoyed doing that
the past couple years and it just I
think it has something to do with the
fact that there's already so much
negativity on the internet and so much
complaining constantly and and all this
like fake screaming and anger about
movies it's like in reality the
filmmaker has the hard job the filmmaker
spends a year two years of his or her
life trying to make something and we
only had to sit there for like 90
minutes and yeah it might suck and trust
me I've seen a lot of shitty movies okay
like and I've always been very honest
about how I feel and I will continue to
be honest about how I feel but it just
doesn't feel like me man it just it
doesn't feel like me when I sit there
and I complain and I and I you know talk
about how much I hated all these movies
if you guys watch my channel this year
you know which movies I hated you know
you can go to my F please
and if you listen to the audio
commentary I recently posted on my
channel then you know what my pick for
the least favorite film of 2018 is but I
just don't want to make the worst of
videos anymore it just it just doesn't
feel right I don't know it might have
something to do with film school being
in film school now or just the fact that
over the past two years I've been making
like an actual professional short film
with a real crew every year and then
trying to release it the festivals but
in reality since I started my channel
I'm trying to keep this brief since I
started my channel my whole thing has
been support film makers you know like
technically yeah I'm reviewing movies
and I'm a member of the be FCA and I'm a
film critic and all that but I was a
filmmaker when I was a kid making shitty
amateur movies with a VHS cam thank my
friends that's that's where my brains
really at and so I I've always wanted to
support filmmakers and and so I don't
know I just don't really feel like
making the worst stuff list I could make
one I can make a video it would get
probably over a million hits and it
would probably give me a lot of
monetization and I'd make more money off
of seeing other people's bad movies and
then talking about them a second time I
just don't really want to do that it
just makes me feel kind of icky and
that's the honest truth and I hope you
guys are okay with that nevertheless I
do want to
genuinely thank you so much for watching
my channel this year the pre-1970s
series anime reviews movie reviews just
tons of fun stuff supporting me the
whole defy media thing and all the great
comments I got from that thank you so
much everybody on patreon you guys are
the best
seriously thank you so much for watching
and I look forward to more coming in
thank you guys have a good one
[Music]
you